so listen congrats on season 3 uh you
know how how much of a fan I am of this
show it doesn't slow down thank you so
much yeah I think this is a great season
I love season 3es in general I just
think that you know especially for
character comedy you know getting
getting the other members of The
Ensemble to have enough like screen time
over the first couple years where you
like totally like everybody involved and
you know you understand where they're
funny and the
cast fire on all cylinders it's just a
it's just a good season I think actually
what do you want to tell people about
season three well I think that it's uh
it's got some cool unique things in the
sense that um there are now uh Nathan
has been downloaded into the real world
and he's reunited with Nora or United
for the first time and their
relationship ship was like very sort of
digital and now it's real and that's got
its own interesting wrinkles and because
he's missing from the uh virtual world
the people at Horizon the low-level
employees kind of panic and they reboot
him in the digital world from a backup
copy that's you know was made a few
months earlier so there's a second
Nathan now in the digital world with uh
Memories the same as the first up into a
point and then they stop so he's unaware
of a lot of things that happened at the
end of season 2 and um so that's like a
kind of an
interesting uh scenario for the romance
uh stories of all the different
characters that now there's two of these
guys although they're slightly different
and they're just starting to diverge
more and more and comedy ues comedy
andus yes so season 3 is Eight Episodes
which is different than season one and
season two
was Eight Episodes a result of story or
because Amazon said or Prime video said
we would like Eight Episodes well you
know Season Two was shot like really in
the middle of the pandemic so um we were
prepared to go eight episodes and then
things started to to get really bad in
Vancouver and uh you know so uh we were
like so we have seven Great episodes
let's stop let's stop now so um and then
you know eight is the eight is a more
normal season I think for these kind of
shows and um they're very jam-packed
like some of them have four or five
storylines and you know I I definitely
feel like this um desire to put as much
entertainment as I can because we've
been thinking about the show for like a
year and a half in between Seasons so
you really want to pack in a lot of a
lot of fun and all the different genres
make sure every everything is hit you
know so without spoilers season 3 ends
in a way that you want season 4 tomorrow
so when when you were writing the end of
season 3 was was was there ever a
thought of wrapping things up or was
Prime video saying you're gonna probably
get a season four let's keep it going
yeah more like the second one I mean
we're we're actually the number one most
viewed half hour show on Prime video so
there it's it's kind of cool they're
they're supportive of the show and um
you know uh I'm pretty optimistic that
we're starting up season 4 soon um so uh
yeah so like hope hopefully I I I I
wouldn't want to end the show on such a
note um you know be really incomplete
feeling well one of the things that I
really liked is that season 3 to me
feels like it's wrapping up a lot of
storylines that were set up in the first
two and opening the door on a whole
another thing is that the way you guys
feel about it as well well I mean I
think that's really
um uh
uh like what you what you do when you're
telling stories right you can't um tease
people forever that nothing's going to
happen something has to happen but um
you don't want it to have this feeling
of closure until you're ready to close
right you so you're always like starting
up new
intriguing uh unanswered questions uh if
you're going to close some things down
uh they should turn into something else
that's interesting and I think that um
you know if you care about the
characters which was always a big
important thing for me then you're going
to care about their adventures and what
happens to them if it matters to them
you know so uh there's still a lot
that's
unanswered uh in the show and um you
know and and and then you know obviously
that's like story structure stuff but on
the level of fun and and you know moment
to moment you know we're trying to
always have good jokes good surprises
like cool
moments so how much were you thinking
about okay well the show is kind of a
hit now like are we basically are you do
you know when you get to the end of
season
three where season 4 is going to go or
is that a thing that you think about
when season 4 starts being written well
I've got a few ideas but I mean the the
thing that's fun about having um a
traditional television show with a room
of writers and the time devoted to weeks
weeks of discussing possible stories and
coming up with things is you know you
want to you want to let that process
happen and um you know when I when I
sold the show back in like 2015 uh I had
two seasons worked out but it was before
casting anybody and you realize when you
cast people you realize oh my gosh these
this person is hilarious like for
instance zanab was not a big character
in my initial um you know Alicia in my
initial uh pitch out but I I just love
watching her and um so she's become
bigger and bigger character and and you
know uh in season three there's like a
big storyline of Alicia becoming
responsible for taking the machine
learning Ai and giving it some kind of
humanity and and value system uh and you
know so that's a really fun Arc for her
this season and um you know pretty
prettyy timely I think when you before
the writer strike happened had you guys
been working on season 4 or is it one of
these things where once or now you're
working on it uh we were supposed to be
starting season 4 in May so it uh we had
to not start the season 4 writers room
because of the
strike uh but everybody made sacrifices
totally
I'm just wondering as a fan of the show
I'm just doing the math of okay well if
the actor strike gets resolved this year
I guess they could be filming early next
year you know what I mean so like the
earliest another season could be on the
air is like
2025 uh I don't know boy that's that's a
bummer but um I mean I I think we're
going to start writing in a week or two
so I I don't I'm not worried about the
actor strike still being going when
we're ready to shoot um but but
uh yeah I mean the the hardest part
about the actress ongoing strike is that
I'm the only person uh uh from that
original group to be able to to press
and they're they're the Charming ones do
you know what I mean they're the ones
that should be going out and and getting
U recognition for all the good work that
they did and it's very frustrating that
uh that they can't when the strike is
over I assure you that I will be asking
to do interviews but for now I am I'm
very happy to be talking to you um okay
cool thanks you didn't direct any
episodes in season 3 did you think about
uh directing I love directing the show
um but it's it's a bear to be the
showrunner of the show and so it's
there's so much
um CP for next week that has to happen
that if I was not around for two weeks
because I was just doing one episode uh
I would worry about things like
um you know I I was able to write two
episodes this year uh and I would love
to direct more I directed the first two
of this show but then you know then
things start to roll and it's just
really it's really difficult and we have
great directors and
um uh you know I really enjoy the stuff
that each of them brings they all have a
slightly different probably more Soph
fisticated than me kind of uh talent
that makes the show better um but I'm
I'm like super involved in the post the
post is really where
uh I have to put in most of the effort
because it takes you know takes such a
long time with all the visual effects
and you have to give rounds and rounds
of notes to the artists and you know no
it's a beast it's a it's a bit of a
beast and you got to start you know you
have to start editing like I I could
maybe direct the last one because I
wouldn't have any more prep but then we
have to be already be editing you know
it would delay the editing
so yeah so I definitely want to ask you
something else uh the last time we spoke
for uh space Force season two uh rip I
wanted a season three on that um we
talked about uh like a possible office
new version of the office and it's been
it's come out that I guess you might be
serious about a new version of the
office is that accurate or is is that
not accurate uh well I think that
there's it's very
speculative um and the fact that it kind
of blew up based on one line in a puck
piece uh was uh kind of cool I guess in
the sense that the fans are very they
still care a lot um but the the thing I
would say is uh when there's something
to announce I will definitely announce
it well you know the thing is it's
because think that article happened
during the writer strike and so you know
there's like for me maybe that's
something you and NBC have been talking
about and you know waiting to announce
after the strike you know like and so I
think that's what people are wondering
well I mean I I've been talking about it
with NBC for years as a as a potential
because they're you
know um into it and uh uh I'm just going
to leave it at that like when when
there's something to announce some good
news I will announce it sure the one
thing I was thinking though if if and
when you actually do this is how much
social media has changed um since the
office was on the air and what that can
bring to story like to storylines and
everything just how technology has
changed in the way we all live our lives
yeah it's an interesting question I mean
um there's so when you watch old movies
it's like a game to to identify what
wouldn't what wouldn't work when there
everybody had a cell phone you know what
I mean like all the story moves of
people like ah they just missed you oh
dang now maybe I'll get on that boat and
go to you know it's just like oh how
frustrating if you only had a cell phone
uh so I I mean that's an interesting
it's an interesting question for sure um
I mean the the funny thing about
technology is is just like on this show
on upload it's like so much about
technology and yet the technology is
still changing so so fast you know what
I mean like there's I mean the the
um uh I did a I was a judge in January
at something called an um AI in film
making hackathon uh at MIT and they did
short films all using some aspect of AI
and like some some used AI to write the
music and others wrote the script and
all this stuff and after it was done I
immediately wrote everybody I knew who
was worked at the writer Guild to be
like guys this is frightening you know
you got to do
something and um and you know that was
like January of 2023 and then in March
you know chat GPT dropped or whenever
that happened and it was just like you
know uh
so
things can be very rapidly changing for
sure that's something that I I I talk
about with with everyone and the fact
that you know it's not about what's
going on in AI today it's what's going
to happen in AI in three years and five
years with the exponential growth of
Computer Learning because it's
frightening what it's gonna be able to
do yeah and and um uh the thing that I
came away from being that judge was I
was like okay so what they're going to
do is they're going to have every single
thing every job in Hollywood is going to
be done by AI potentially and what it
means is that and also when you combine
that with like Netflix's algorithm
knowing what you like and which your
favorite actors are that you're going to
be given a very personalized movie you
know uh and it's going to be all
generated off scripts of stuff you've
liked and and sort of Blended and and
then they're going to have you know a
way to take Tom Hanks and you know Betty
Davis and just make them the same age
and you know have them be in the movie
together or whatever it's crazy I heard
and take this with a grain of salt but I
heard that they're one of the reasons
why so many companies are going after
like life rights is because we're
reaching the point where technology
eventually it's not right now but soon
we'll be able to take like Humphrey
Bogart from the 40s combine him with
Bruce Lee from the early 70s and put
them in a buddy cop movie or whatever
the hell you're looking for
right like it looks like a movie yeah
they'll be able to do that and I think
they'll also be able to say wait your
favorite guy is Humphrey bogat and your
second favorite guy is Bruce Lee let's
let's sort of mush them together and do
some kind of Humphrey Lee you know
mashup character that only you will see
in this movie and that'll just blow
you'll be so excited I I don't know yeah
it's it's such a weird thing and then on
the other hand I think there's a lot of
probably puffery to it you know what I
mean like uh I don't know if it'll ever
work I mean it looks like it's going to
work but there's so many reasons why big
companies like Netflix want you to
believe that they're going to be able to
do this and have like a no cost movie
that people want to see it's such a good
story for their stock price that I just
sometimes you got to take it with a
grain of salt I think like I said I I
think that it's not about what's
happening today and it's not what's
happening in a year it's it's the three
five and 10 years from now you just look
at what an iPhone used to do and what an
iPhone can do now it's really that
simple and that's what's going to come
to AI well it's interesting to see where
sag is going to end up because I feel
like if they don't if they don't
regulate it then it'll be on everybody's
individual contracts and all of the all
the new actor contracts will probably
have some language in it that says oh by
the way if something happens to you we
we get to make this character forever
using what we on you that's the whole
thing about and that's what I was saying
about likeness rights because there are
people going around trying to get
likeness rights for Life yeah well we
did that with um the show the the the
character there's a character like a a
sort of not too successful actor named
Boris Netherlands and he is the basis
for the AI Guy character in upload and
he was paid
$1,200 back in the day and they scanned
him and he gets nothing and he's really
bitter about it and it's just like oh my
God that's what they're striking over I
know I have to run I know they're going
to kill me but I just want to ask you
one last question about upload so what
what I'm curious about is you have uh oh
my God I'm butchering on the name of the
is Horizons um yeah and so horizons you
have the gray Zone uh and my question is
are the upload companies all existing in
this is real geeky are all existing in
one sort of after life world or does
each company exist in its own place sort
of like the way nfts are where they're
not really connected do you see what I
mean yeah yeah I mean my uh uh imagin I
mean obviously it's all fake but my
imagination is that um the gry zone is
pretty much cyberspace and so if it's
all on whatever the worldwide web is
then it's going to be on the gry Zone if
that's the system that's being used you
know so so if you are going to walk away
walk out of if you're digital yourself
and you can somehow crack out of um
Horizon and just walk through this un
undifferentiated nothingness that is the
experience that people used to have when
they walked off a Call of Duty map into
nowhere's land remember and that
eventually You' you'd stumble into the
Apple version uh Apple's Cove and it
would be different it'd be a beach theme
and the whole thing would be there but
you could walk into it you know in the
same way you walk out of the Wizard of
Oz if you walk out of Oz you go through
a desert and then you get to you know
the real world eventually nice to talk
with you sir and I wish you nothing but
the best thank you so much you
too